[Music]
today Jean Fay who was sitting here in
the front row and I will be talking
about hybrid mash so how do we add vm's
to our environment can I get a show of
hands how many of you been to an SEO
talk here at the show okay great
we'll probably repeat a few things but
there were some people who didn't raise
their hands so we'll do some level
setting as well as we go through here so
okay here's the summary this is all you
need to remember is CEO works on VMs if
that's the only thing you get out of
this talk that's that's the thing I want
you to walk out of this room with SEO
does work on VMs so most of you that
have been to if CEO presentations here
you've read articles you've read the
documentation about sto for the most
sort of talks about kubernetes so how
does this tea I worked on clusters we're
going to show you how to extend that to
VMs today so I said we'd do a little bit
of level setting so first let's talk
about what SEO is just for those people
they're new to this and just talked
about SEO we have to talk about a
service mesh so what is the surface mesh
service meshes work at the network layer
so you put them in they are transparent
to the application that means we don't
care what language the application is
written in whether it's Java or C sharp
or go or node or whatever it just
doesn't matter because we're working at
the network layer and mesh provides some
level of functionality
whether it's telemetry or some network
controls a service mesh provides that
kind of capability and there are many
service meshes out there
SDO is probably the most common one that
you've heard about but there are other
service meshes as well so let's talk
about sto specific specifically then it
is a service mesh but we think it's much
more than that it's an open services
platform because we've designed so many
sensibility points into sto again it
works on containers and
p.m. so we can bring in the full
environment you can plug in different
monitoring solutions you can plug in all
kinds of access control solutions so it
really is a platform that allows you to
really control your services both what's
going on at the network level and
monitoring all that information so what
is the value proposition of SEO then we
break it down into these three things
uniform observability because we're at
the network layer we see all the network
traffic and we know what's going on on
the network and we can send all that
telemetry information to the mixer which
is part of the control plane and the
mixer then can forward it on to wherever
you want that telemetry information to
go whether that's stackdriver on GCE or
GCP or Prometheus or data dog wherever
you want your your logging information
to go we can do that through the mixer
we provide operational agility so that
means that you can do canary rollouts
you can do Bluegreen rollouts you can
inject faults into the network if you
want to test the resiliency of your
services you can set quotas if you've
ever had a service accidently do a DOS
attack on one of your other services
then you might want to set quotas on
your services and then the third thing
we can do is policy driven security so
we can set encryption on this on all the
communication going on on the network so
we use mutual TLS that means we set
strong identities for the service we
know the identity of every service
running in the mesh and we know that
service a is talking to service B and we
can so you see that service B is talking
to service C and you may think service a
is talking to service C but again by
looking at the telemetry you could see
maybe that's not happening for some
reason so we can do all three of these
things then these are very important
value props of this deal okay as I
mentioned most of the documentation most
of the things you see about sto talk
about a cluster
and our control plane runs in kubernetes
so I've got kubernetes shown in the
middle here but as you probably know
most of the enterprise workloads
actually still run on VMs and there are
lots of good reasons for that the first
one is data stores so when I talk to
customers probably the first thing that
comes up is data stores they're running
they're my sequel they're Postgres
they're Oracle database they're
Cassandra they're Couchbase whatever it
is and there's a whole laundry list of
them many many data stores run on VMs
today and many many enterprises have no
intention of moving those in the near
term some people are moving them to
kubernetes and communities is much
better home better now with those but a
lot of them are still on GM's and will
be for quite a while then there's
packaged software it's a black box right
you get it from some vendor whether it's
a CRN application HR application
whatever it is and the vendor says this
needs to run on this release of Linux
it needs X amount of RAM X amount of CPU
that's where you'll run it if you want
support so as a company you really don't
have any choice that's gonna run a VM
there's existing software enterprises
have written lots of software on VMs so
in the last year in the last five years
the last ten years those services are
running they will be for a long time and
new applications are being written on
VMs all the time in most of your
enterprises you guys are still writing
writing software on VMs and rolling out
new applications so we really want to
bring all these things into the SEO mesh
and provide all those value props to you
on these VMs ok so that's kind of this
set up in the level setting so the rest
of this is really going to be so how do
we do that how do we bring VMs into this
environment so this diagram is a picture
of a kubernetes cluster with this deal
to simplified representation I just show
us on here or service 1 and service 2
now each one of those services is some
number of pods let's say
service one is three pods and service
two is ten pods because we have sto
running on here those services those
pods are running histiocytes as well
so imagine service one and surface two
are broken out into those pods and
they're running the sto side cars we
have the control playing components here
on the right
mixer pilot and Citadel pilot is pushing
out the policy to all the co sidecars
it's the one that tells it how to direct
traffic and and all those kind of things
what the security policy should be mixer
is getting all the requests from the
from the SPO side cars and the proxies
it's getting all that to limitary
information and then forwarding on to in
what Chantay will show you in a minute
is prometheus in our case and then
citadel is the CA the certification
authority so it's providing the
certificates for the strong
authentication between services over on
the left are the ingress and egress
gateways into and out of the cluster so
this is what a standard communities
cluster looks like with this Geo
installed and again for those of you
that have been to other talks this is
kind of where this story stops but what
we want to do is bring in VMs into this
story right so again to to more simple
services on here service 3 and service 4
so how do we add VMs to this world well
there's some setup there's some setup we
have to do and we obviously have to
install some software we're gonna put
the Envoy proxy on to these VMs I don't
actually show up but there's another
component that goes on the VMS as well
it's the node agent and that's the thing
that talks to Citadel and is doing the
certificate renewal and so forth so we
have the Envoy proxy the node agent that
we get installed in that on the VMS and
then we have to tell the cluster how to
communicate with the VMS and the VMS how
to communicate with the cluster so one
of the important things in that scenario
is this service entry so you see these
little boxes here by the arrows that go
to the VMS those are service entries a
service entry
a CRD that gets installed into the
cluster as part of the sto install so
let's take a look at that as I mentioned
it's a CR D it's configurable resource
definition this is the way you extend
kubernetes and tell it about new
resources this is a service entry it's
what 20 lines of the Amalur so and this
is all we need to do to supply the
cluster with information about services
on VMs so some specific information in
here the top box there is the service
entry that just says what type of
configurable resource this is so again
this is the extension to kubernetes and
then we're going to provide some
information about what the service is in
this case the name of the service I just
grabbed this camel right now the is do
documentation so it's a simple example
the name is the VM HTTP we have to tell
it what the fully qualified name of the
host is so here is VM HTTP dot service
namespace so again we're dealing with a
crew Nettie's control plane and
communities has namespaces so we have to
tell it where this service is going to
live what namespace is going to live in
you can create a new name space for your
VMs you can put it in existing
namespaces I think actually the demo
you'll see in a few minute just uses the
default namespace but it's it's totally
up to you you just have to put these
things in a namespace and then some more
information about the what the address
of the actual host is you need to know
how to communicate with it so we have
the GCC PGCE
IP address and then we have some labels
so again kubernetes uses labels and sto
uses labels for things like Canary
rollouts and directing traffic so we're
going to add some labels to this service
as well so that's all there is to
service entry again fairly short it's a
you just do a cube control apply to
enter this information into the
kubernetes cluster
okay so let's pop back a level we we
dove down into the CR D but let's talk
about what you actually have to do for
the full set up of adding a VM to your
service mesh and this is right from the
SEO documentation this is just a summary
of this so first you have to enable mesh
expansion this is just a boolean flag on
the ISTE oh install by default mesh
expansion is turned off you just have to
turn it on it's a one-time operation for
the first VM you add and then if you add
another 100 VMs it doesn't matter you
don't have to change that flag you have
to choose a namespace for where these VM
services are going to go as I showed in
that CRD when you register the service
you have to say what namespace that
services associated with you have to add
the ingress clot or the IP of the
ingress gateway to the cluster to the VM
so the VM is going to communicate with
the control plane it needs to know where
to send the telemetry information that
information goes to mixer and so we're
gonna get to mixer through the ingress
ingress gateway in the cluster so you
have to tell the vm ware that ingress
gateway is you're obviously going to
have to install the software on the vm
the proxy and the node agent you can do
that just through the the package
install and then step six and seven
these are either or or maybe both step
six is if you have a vm that's talking
to services inside the cluster so that
the communication is going from the vm
to a service in the cluster then you
have to tell the VM where that service
is so you just add its IP address and
information to Etsy hosts in the sample
we're going to show you the other cases
where you've got the cluster talking to
the VM this is a very common case this
is that datastore case that I talked to
customers about so they've got say a
Postgres database running on a VM that
they need access from the cluster so now
you have to tell the cluster services
how to get to the VM you just create
that service entry that yamo file I
talked about do a cube control apply on
that file and then you have to add the
to the DNS in the cluster so that's all
there is to it it's fairly simple and
actually Jean pay is going to show you
exactly how to do that so we're going to
go through two demos the first one is to
set up the second one is the hipster app
and again if you've been to other
presentations you've probably seen the
hipster app already this is just an
e-commerce website where you can go and
buy things all the other demos have had
all these services running on the
cluster
so in kubernetes and again you can see
they're written in lots of different
languages it doesn't matter - is do we
can get all the telemetry and do all the
controls no matter the language I've
circled one at the bottom here this
catalog service where John Fay is going
to show you is that catalog service
running on a VM and then he's even gonna
go further and show you some traffic
redirection so chante
thank you Chris hi everyone my name is
Jan Fay I'm working at a Google you see
all open source projects today I will
show you the demo of how to install the
issue of this setup and then run some
SEO feature to manage your service micro
service across the VM and the community
cluster
okay let's switch to the demo so first
of all for the all the instructions and
setups that I'm doing today you can find
the information on Easter at all io web
site and here you can find the setup and
how to run the workloads on the VM and
what kind of operations you need for the
this kind of setup so please check it
out
and so the app as you probably already
heard of a lot of times at an X that is
the hipster shop app people can come to
this website and it shows the favorite
items you'd like and the pick up to your
cart and check it out so it works
perfectly everything it is it's a micro
service based architecture everything is
a micro service they are communicating
with each other using jaribg protocols
and they if you enable it still you get
all the benefits of the e steel security
telemetry and the traffic management out
of the box
great so except once in the product
catalog service is somehow still runs on
the VM and you still want to wire things
together and behave as a single mesh so
we are going to just do it to it so the
first of seeing of course you need to
select this a user GCP project because
this is next and you need to choose a
Jiki cluster and you need to choose a GC
VM that is hosting the VM application
workload we are doing the set of wire a
some environment variable sorry this
should be hipster product catalog
all right and by the way for today's
demos peppers that I prepare a bear
script to automate a lot of steps but in
sensually that is all the same as what
you can find on East Ohio web page let's
take a look how that very quick
there's batch automation looks like so
pretty much that you can see it we need
to create the cluster and install the
east created the GC VM download it you
steal and the install is still so
there's nothing special over there let's
just go ahead back to the demo and use
the automation
cool so first of the first you need to
install is deal we smash expansion
enable we are only set up and this will
try to download it still and use your GK
cluster install the is do with its
special hand flag enabled the mesh
expansion as Chris just mentioned that
the instill of mash expansion to run the
VM you intentionally need to expose the
easier control play to the VM workloads
so such that the m'boy on the VM know
how to communicate with the user control
plane like pilot to get the my XDS
configuration is you know the agent then
can also reach out to the CA Citadel in
the cluster to get the key and serve
refreshed and also for the mixer you
need to report the telemetry data back
to the Prometheus great so we we just
finish the installation and now we need
to do another thing to set up the GC VM
we are run another command for that
purpose as you can see other than
command we have a three five five zero
port that is the port value the VM
applications the product catalog service
specifically that we are listen others
three five five zero and let's go ahead
and see what we are doing there the
first thing is to generate get some
configuration from the cluster it
determines the IP range of the service
in the cluster and the second thing is
to get the key insert for this VM
workloads
remember Chris just mentioned that you
need to choose a name space and a
service count took we present the
workload on the VM as that VM workload
identity so for our demos purpose we
just choose the default and default
service account if our name space but
you can choose whatever you like cool so
this kind of configuration now is dump
it to your workstation and then you need
to copy the over to your GC v n which is
essentially just a g-cloud compute SCP
command line you can see that a bunch of
configuration has been configured a copy
to the GC instance once we have all
those configuration being copied over
now it's time to run some automation on
the GC instance so this part of the
script now we are be running inside of
that VM instance so as you can see that
the gate we expose they put the gateway
IP a public IP on to the /et c / host so
the Envoy can use the name and is your -
pilot to resolve the address of the user
control plane through gateway and this
party is just trying to download the
issue of Debian package that will be
installed on the VM operating system and
we also need to copy the key cert to the
designated
file system path for the my - talking
yes all right
and the very last step you every other
you set up everything you can now start
the e steel component on that VN which
specifically is just you steal my you
use for intercept to the traffic and you
still know the agent that is responsible
for refreshing the key and a third after
you before it expires oh that's it let's
say second steps so now you have both
sto installed in your cuneta cluster and
you have the VM that is ready to run
some applications actually if you just
type some from your applications on that
VM the employ is ready to intercept the
traffic and you can find other services
in the kinetic cluster and we are ready
to go
however there is one scene that is
missing that is their service discovery
as Chris just mentioned because for the
applications that inside of the canary
cluster they don't know there is some
service running on this VM we need kind
of service discovery mechanism to model
these VM services the easier to handle
this as we know just learnt it's using
service entry so we basically need to
write some CRD to of the service entry
to map instruct vm service to a list of
the endpoints so here we choose the name
of the services product catalog services
and the port value is three five five
zero match what we just used and the
protocol is the GRP see that's the three
arguments for this command great we just
do that so this essentially to two
things first is to create a service
entry that to this IP of deviance and
the second thing is to create a common
area service selector service the
purpose of the other is that when you
create a service in the community
cluster you will the cubanelle is able
to return a corresponding
as record for the workers in the kinetic
luster to resolve so you can the kinetic
cloud applications can use the names
instead of IPs and so let's take a look
what's the service entry we just
generated it looks like alright
sorry need to output gamma file alright
so as you can see probably need to screw
up a little bit so this is a service
entry CRD and the name is coda catalog
service - door VN we use that in oddly
is a service running on the VM and you
can see in the spec parts the first it's
the end points the end points list the
list of the end points that is
responsible for backing up as a service
in each end point you can specify the
the IP address which is in our case is
the VM IP address to run the hipster
product catalog service and you can also
put the labels over there labels for you
are familiar with [ __ ] aliases you can
put the denotation on for the employment
and you can use labels to select manage
your workload later and as you can see
here we put the register column low VM
levels here and we are taking advantage
of that in the our follow-up demo and of
course you need to specify the house the
name of the service and the port is
three five five zero protocol is G RPC
and that's it cool
so actually we know that is pretty much
everything you need to do for the VM
setup match expansion and of course you
need to run your applications product
service product catalog service on that
VM but we are going to skip that part
and go switch to a cluster that we
already finish that part
so for these hipster app everything he
spells through a front-end ingress and
here is the public IP of the in front
and ingress let's send some requests to
these app to see what is going on there
so you keep hit the refresh button a
couple times and oh okay so here we go
as you can see sometimes it is show a
list of their products sometimes it only
shows one product why that is the case
because we actually run the product
catalog service on both cuneta cluster
and on the GC vm in some sense this
single service is spanning across
different platforms whether it's on the
VM or it is on kinetic cluster from a
match point of view it doesn't matter
and so for to create a visual
differential very distinguishable effect
we curated the items to only retain one
product item on the VM version and for
the kubernetes one we have more products
for you to buy from so and if you're not
by the default case when you are not
using any advanced virtual service the
kind of routing configuration is
randomly select either one of the end
point either is VM endpoint or the pod
in the kinetic coaster so it is 50 by 50
chest and we are we are see that through
the dashboard later cool so now let's
send some traffic to simulate the real
customer traffic we have a Python script
to generate some traffic to against that
front end so let's stop
let's let me explain a little bit of
what these PES group is doing so this
person transcript is sending some
required to the front-end and parse the
HTML and if it is only return one items
then we know it is from the VM and if it
is returns more items then in his front
corner cluster the so in such a way that
we can count the accumulated requests
that is either handler by the community
cluster or they handled by the VM
workload and so as you can see this is
roughly 50 and 50 there's just pure
random we are gonna just run this
squeeze continuously to generate some
traffic now we as you know one of the
value proposition for easier is to have
the other part elementary feature and
let me show you on the coroner dashboard
so here is the graph enna probably I
need to sue me a little bit so we choose
the namespace default which and the
workload the you can see here there is
both product catalog service and product
catalog - yo V N and there is product
catalog service the upper part this part
result is the culinary version that is
using the Canaries deployment name to
denote the worker name and the second
part is match it's what we used in their
service entry and we use this for the VM
workload let's refresh it as you can see
that so it has some QP as to QP s and
this is the respond by response code at
200 and it works great
let's do another tab side-by-side to see
the traffic that is running on the
canary cluster
and it's three coop years so it's not
that accurate but it is roughly as at
like 50 percent by 50% so you get the
telemetry a feature for from the East
deal now let's say you want to protect
your traffic you want to enable the
mutually else handled by the employ you
don't need to do anything all your
applications so we are for that we are
just write some authentication policy so
as you as some of you familiar with the
East do we use authentication policy to
configure the server side security
requirement basically we say for this
service for this port will require you
to either the client needs to talk in
muted curls or you need to give me a job
for you for our purposes we are just
using materials and we have some CRD
here let's take a look of how that looks
like the policy specified the product
catalog service and the materials we
specify the mode as the strict or so
that is for server-side requirements
that you client you please talking muted
here otherwise I will reject and for
their client side that is the
destination rule destination rule tells
how the client my what kind of mutual
care settings you need to use when talk
to the specific server so we specify
used to mutual and here so that client
and server both we are using expected
results
so let's apply these Yama file and as
you can see the post policy and the
destination rule now has been configured
we are expecting the traffic we are
shifting from the plane tax so the
mutual chaos that's verified that our
graph in our dashboard just you take a
cup of seconds for the CRD from the API
server to go to the pilot and then goes
to my let me refresh it
Oh actually you can see that now you the
the traffic has been swap it from the
yellow to the green from the yellow you
can see that is it's nothing there but
if you hand me over to the AH to the
Green Line you can see there is a column
mutual curious which showed means that
your traffic now is encrypted and
protected and this behavior is same
consistently regardless whether you run
your VM on the applications on the VM or
your canary cluster you can see both of
them get swap different from the
plaintiff community else awesome so we
finished the music security part now
that's talking about the networking
management so you run your applications
on the VM and you run something on the
cuneta cluster imagine that you want to
migrate something from the VM to the
connect cluster and you want to control
this process and please enroll their
migration with competence you still
support that Y or advance ourselves in
volume using virtual service and you
just you write some virtual service 3rds
to configure how much percentage of the
traffic you want to send to the and one
of the subsets which is community
cluster
how much you want to send to the VM code
subset we also have already have some
theory for that
here we go so the first part again is
the destination rule and in the
destination rule we other than the
tailor settings we also specified two
subsets the first one is the kubernetes
one is user labels labels that basically
for the workload that has AB column a
product catalog service these labels
that we are mixer as part of the
canaries subset and for the end point
that has the registry color with your VM
these labels that we think that is a row
VM the VM part of the subset so remember
that the registry columns or VM these
labels that is exactly what you just put
in the service entry basically in the
Canaries you put the levels in your
deployment and in the service entry we
have the same functionality for you to
attach labels and they use use that to
define the subsets once you defines a
subset of our service you can then use
the virtual service for the routing as
you can see that for the Canaries subset
we use 80% and for the VM part we use
20% so we are expecting after apply this
to CRTs the more traffic from 50 will
jump to the 80th for the Canaries
traffic and the VM will get less traffic
all right so the configuration has been
applied now what we are expecting is the
drop in line of on the vient
refiner dashboard and we are seeing a
bump up in the community's workload so
this might take a couple of seconds but
here we go so you can see the lines
dropping down from around to QPS to one
QPS and on the other hand the kubernetes
workload is significantly and pop
because the traffic is more more traffic
is routed to the qunari cluster so but
these seems alright mmm
and as you as you have more confidence
you can continue to use the virtual
service for 12 more traffic to your
Canaries aversion and finally get rid of
your VM workload but the that's our demo
and to summarize the takeaway that you
have some VM walks out and you want to
migrate to quit any cluster you want to
have the service match cause different
environments and you may even want to
microwave something from the VM to the
cogniat cluster and stok help you to
finish that journey with confidence is
by having telemetry and showing you what
is going on in that process thank you
okay thanks chef eh
okay that that was a lot of information
packed into that demo we went from
essentially a bear cluster and a VM to
installing sto and getting it all
configured in five to ten minutes and
then actually going through showing you
an application showing you the the
features of sto and giving you all of
these all these features of Sto the
Uniform observability the operational
agility and the policy-driven security
across not only your kubernetes cluster
but across your VMs as well whether it's
the migration scenario John pages talked
about of how do you take your VM
workload and bring it into the
kubernetes cluster over time giving you
a kind of a canary rollout or whether
it's your VMs that are gonna continue to
run for the next one to five years
whatever it is with that database out
there you can bring those VMs in to your
to your mash so that's how you make a
hybrid environment
Shantay talked about the documentation
it's all up here the mesh expansion is a
little hidden it you have to go to the
community site and then you go to the
mesh expansion but that has all the
instructions on how to do this yourself
and then there's the Dory link at the
bottom
[Music]